l'ancien fosso de douala au cameroun
était avec nous aujourd'hui à nouveau
bonjour martien alors manciet tu as une
question sur le canada à laquelle tu
penses que l'on pourrait répondait la
réponse pour intéresser les autres trucs
sont et les côtes
on n'a peut-être pas le pont le plus
long au monde mais on a déjà eu le pont
le plus long au monde
à la belle époque en 1860 d'accord moi
je le traversait récemment enfin
récemment pendant des années j'habitais
au sud de montréal entre montréal et
l'autre côté du fleuve saint laurent et
au sud de l'île de montréal
on retrouve ce pont victoria qui a été
construit en deux étapes parfaite et une
en 1860 c'était le pont déjà le plus
long au monde
on parlait d'un pont construit en tube
on a changé la technologie autour de
on a enlevé les tubes mais le pont est
resté et c'était le pont le plus
longuement 2742 mètres de longueur on
parle ici donc d'à peine 2,7 km de
langue à meilhan dans l'histoire du
canada deux autres pompes dont il faut
absolument parler en fait y en a trois
le pont de la ville de québec qui a été
construit on a débuté la construction en
1900 c'était considéré à ce moment là le
plus long pont quand ils hiver qui soit
il s'est écroulé à deux reprises 1907
1916 en pleine construction ils ont eu
des problèmes énormes
c'était le plus gros au monde comprend
alors il avait beaucoup de difficultés
avec les écrous et ç'a eu un impact dit
on à travers toute la planète au niveau
de la construction des ponts
l'écrasement du pont de québec
et si tu vas aujourd'hui à québec sera
qu'à côté de ce pont de québec il ya
aussi le plus long pont suspendu au
canada le pont le plus long canada il
relie deux provinces une qui se trouve
dans l'enceinte l'océan atlantique et
l'autre qui bordent l'océan atlantique
je sais pas si tu as une bonne idée de
la géographie du canada mais est-ce que
tu serais le nom d'une des provinces qui
est relié par ce pont qu'on appelle le
pont de la confédération
non ce n'est pas en colombie est annexée
c'est dans l'océan atlantique
il faut regarder
atlantic atlantique nouveaux produits
oui vos brunswick
exact oui et tout à fait tout à fait
c'est encore aujourd'hui le plus long
pont au monde au dessus d'une étendue
maritime prise par les glaces
oui c'est à dire que c'est le pont le
plus long qui peut capable de résister
aux glaces aux iceberg
parce qu'il y en a qui se promènent par
là et là sa frappe le ponton y en a pas
tous les jours qui viennent heurter le
pont mais il fallait quand même
construire quelque chose de solide pour
laisser penser les iceberg en dessous ou
encore laisser passer les vents parce
que les vents sont très forts alors
voilà ça c'est peut-être le plus beau
grand pont canadien là celui qui fait
travailler le plus d'imagination
aujourd'hui bon en parlant de ça
j'imagine qu'on va avoir des auditeurs
qui vont vouloir aussi savoir quel est
le pont le plus long au monde
est ce que toi tu l'aurais fait une
recherche par rapport à saturer des
réponses des éléments de réponse je ne
sais pas tu es tombé pile ça a été
confirmé le 20 mars 2008 que le pont le
plus long au monde a été achevé ce
jour-là il assure une liaison routière
de 36 kilomètres à travers la mer de
chine orientale a précédemment le pont
le plus long c'est toujours dans la
région de l'asie c'était le pont de
donghai donghai qui signifie grand pont
de la mer orientale là aussi c'était en
chine
et ça a été terminé en 2005 et la
distance totale du pont 32,5 km dont 26
km en continu au dessus de la mer et pas
tellement loin de la ville de shanghai
du temps d'accord il ya aussi un pont
très important et ça j'ai vu un
reportage à la télévision c'est le pont
de la baie de gaulle ou au dessus de la
baie de wenzhou 25 kilomètres de laon
gare alors c'était martien fausse
l'auditeur à douala au cameroun